cause you're just a man  honestly is any kind of milk sacred  these days okay folks let's go over this  one quick oats contained carbohydrates  bound up with fiber which slows down its  blood sugar response and also improves  it's satiety profile oat milk will have  lower amounts of that fiber so in that  sense it's going to create a greater  blood sugar response than Whole Food  oats but that doesn't mean that it's  pure sugar nor is it horrifically bad  for you it actually does have small  amounts of fiber protein and a ton of  other essential nutrients and it's a  great option if you have food  intolerances or allergies to things like  nuts Dairy and soy and it tastes great  so for goodness sakes can we stop trying  to find fault with every [ __ ] food oh